[Music]
what is the difference between
resurrection and translation all right
translation
means the absence of death as you move
from earth to heaven enoch was
translated that he should not see death
uh hebrews 11
verse 5 enoch was translated that he
should not see death a translated person
does not experience death moses was
resurrected but he was not translated he
was resurrected elijah was translated
enoch was translated moses was
resurrected and taken to heaven so when
in matthew 17 verses 1 to 5
enoch not you know yes enoch
elijah and moses appear with christ on
the mount of transfiguration elijah
represented those who will not see death
will go straight to heaven
moses represents those who will die and
then be resurrected and so translation
means no experience of death enoch and
elijah resurrection is you die then you
come up moses represents that truth
now the 144 000 will be translated they
will not see death
it's a tremendous privilege to not see
death and go straight to the kingdom
it's a tremendous honor it will preserve
an entire group in the past two people
have experienced that as far as we know
enoch and elijah before christ when
christ comes the last in the second time
an entire group of people a church will
be translated
hallelujah i'm looking forward to that
day by god's grace yes and i'm looking
forward to that day and just to add a
text to what you said in first
corinthians chapter 15 verse 51 the
bible says we shall not all sleep
that's right let's all be changed that's
right
that's right that's very true
amen
means death
pardon
sleep means death in the bible sleep is
death we shall not all sleep we shall
not all die
but whether you resurrected or
translated you have to be changed
that's that's right and i think that's
where the spiritual application of the
resurrection comes in because paul talks
about dying daily yes he does
but dying daily to self into sin
we're killed we're killed all the day
long and for thy sake we're killed all
the day long is a constant dying a
constant resurrection yes
amen amen
[Music]
you